We can use this to now start
building response curves.
So this was what we had in the last
slide, which basically had the log of
exposure, pixel values, and
these were the three different points.
And we were able to trace them out
in equally, all three of them.
Now assuming unit radiance for
each pixel,
we basically can kind of start
making an interesting model here.
So what we want to do now is take this
and start kind of figuring out how to
align them so
then they would have a uniform shape.
So in essence what I took.
The purple values and I want to be
able to shift the turquoise and
the yellow to create a unique profile.
And basically what that means is I'm
adjusting the radiances to open,
to obtain a smooth response curve.
So I take all three of them,
I basically adjust them out a little bit
to create a nice, smooth response curve.
Once I have this I have actually
gone far in trying to be able
to create an inverse G,
purely from there.
Again, remember, G is basically
giving me this information.
I want to be able to get intensity
values and come the other way.